so Mr Olympia do you have any
predictions you kind of have an idea you
know right now uh you have the reigning
Champion uh big Grammy yeah
um more than likely he is the favorite
he is the guy that's gonna repeat
who's standing in his way is uh Hadi
Chopin from Iran yep he's trained by my
trainer Hani rambot and I've been able
to see some pics
uh he's looking really dangerous right
now what's the chances of hottie beating
Grammy I think it's
all about who Peaks not just on Friday
but who slams the door on Saturday I
definitely feel that the way the judging
criteria is this is not swayed to just
rammy because rammy has only peaked
through truly maybe a couple times in
his career and I know his trainer Chad
Nichols who trained Ronnie Coleman who
worked with him for all those Olympia
wins understands
how imperative it is to not just do
Friday but also Saturday the timing of
it the timing is everything I mean
that's something that I you know made
sure of but with hottie he does not
Miss
so I think with rammy being the size
that he is he can miss maybe one of
those days so and then you have Brandon
Curry I mean you know he's a former Mr
Olympia he's a one-time so that's really
your top three and I'm really excited to
see those three guys get up there and
then you have the guys like William
bonak you have Nick Walker Nick Walker
who just won the Arnold Classic yeah a
lot of hype going in yeah it's it's
gonna but Nick win couldn't does Nick
stand a chance to be first place no okay
no top three maybe if some guys miss how
big of a deal is it to win the Arnold
Classic going into Mr O like is it a
really really big deal or not I think
this year it helps him tremendously
because of the fact that the Arnold was
two weeks prior to the Olympia normally
the Arnold Classic is in March so you
have like that six months yeah is it
healthy Phil to have it to be that close
to each other like Mr Olympia and Arnold
I mean health-wise that's gotta be it's
definitely difficult to to peek for a
two-day show doing a one-day show I mean
that's easy yeah but when you're doing a
one day show and then two weeks after
you know the peaking what do you mean
what do you mean by Peak and fill and
like how long is that window you're
talking so you have to consider like
let's just say you have a Usain Bolt
he's getting ready for the Olympics but
he's doing like an event like an
Invitational like let's say a month
prior
let's just say he wants a world record
time in the world you know before the
Olympics is that smart probably not
because you really want to win the
Olympic final with the world record time
so it's all about the timing so you kind
of have to pace yourself but the problem
is the body is not static it's very very
Dynamic so whatever worked for Nick or
anyone for these previous shows you have
to now realize that diet that training
you might want to just rip that up and
just look at what's going on with your
body right now
and that's something that a lot of
people
Miss
so a lot of people that even watch this
they've dieted but because of the fact
that their body does change and they
didn't change with it yeah they they
miss so that's why all these fad dice
keep going so but bodybuilders have that
problem too so so you got for you like
let's just say by the way does Vegas
have odds on these things or no does
Vegas they should they don't but they
don't okay why not because
yeah it's kind of sticky with the that's
very uh
oh 100.
Mr Olympia can be bought oh
okay I'm not sitting here I'm not
judging anybody I'm not sitting here and
saying it happens but
when they're like Pat said there's a
reason why there's no Vegas odds in this
I mean people could be compromised in
some way shape or form I mean we don't
need to go down there you think that's a
good thing that there's nothing in Vegas
yeah I think so one million percent yeah
the Integrity of it one million at least
in boxing you know you boxing is one of
the dirtiest when it comes down to
manipulating and buying people out I've
had people on that have told me you have
no idea what kind of people I've bought
and how much how easy it is to buy that
right in bodybuilding it's very uh uh
what do you call it it's you know
technical yet you can kind of say well
objective yes objective that's the word
so you can be objective yet subjective
so like if you look at all the Mr
Olympia Champions they're all different
in their own way
so right now you have rammy like that's
a guy that is I love Grammy I would like
to see there's no one that looks like
Ramy right like a big Romy guy so
there's no one that looks like him he's
like he's like the modern day Ronnie
right there it's not a run the guy's
gonna be over 300 pounds ripped oh damn
no one's gonna look like this yeah Kai
pull up some images of these guys who
are we looking okay no no do the one
with Ronnie and uh Romney right next to
each other even though it's not real
click on that no no this is my Instagram
post if you can pull it around me look
at that right there to two of them
insane what Robbie looks like
if it was as big as these guys when he
was winning the ball I was definitely
not the same weight as rammy you know
even Grammy's on the right yes and
Ronnie's on the left yeah so like when
my last Olympia win in 2017 I actually
did
um beat rammy and uh you beat the guy on
the right yeah damn Phil I beat these
guys were over 10 plus years bro you're
back to back to back I know who feels
this but uh but Remy is definitely one
of those guys that even when I was
winning yeah I would see him and say
if this guy gets in real good shape yeah
he's gonna be a problem for everybody
second place
Rami Hadi uh probably Brandon Mick
I don't have you know what's funny I I
actually my Oddball is William bonak
because he didn't do the Arnold
and I think it gave him maybe more time
to Peak for the Olympia could it be top
three I think so I mean like it's just
well here's my money my money would be a
1a1b with hottie and rammy because
they're so different yet dude if hottie
wins oh man it's sort of crazy if he
wins this is rammy right here go on
hottie Chopin yeah Chopin wins the
Olympia I may have to drive up to
Orlando congratulations
zero h-a-d-i yeah there you go there you
go but click on that everybody's looking
for that there you go they want that
this is what people want they want easy
is he Indian hottie the guy on the right
is Persian so they want they want Egypt
Egypt versus Iran basically is that oh
he's Egyptian he's ironic but Romney's
twice his size
look at the legs but look at even but
here's the thing yeah
look at look at Remy but then look at
hottie deeper Cuts uh-huh you know much
deeper separation so these are things
that like this is this is the judging
this has to be seen live because to me
that there's it's indecipherable so so
it's so here's what I would suggest what
if Phil on Saturday night okay
what if you go live and you watch Mr
Olympia live and you give feedback on it
and anybody that wants to tune in they
can tune in and see you giving feedback
on the contest [ __ ] it I say we do it
you're not gonna go no I'm not going
you're not going I'm not going so okay
why not why not why why wouldn't the
fans want to see me do commentary on on
the guys you'd rather you'd rather at
the end of the day I mean I'm going to
give these guys Justice okay you know I
definitely feel that um they would want
to know my opinion yeah but more
importantly I've competed against these
guys for over 10 years I understand
their strengths their weaknesses
but um I have no ax to grind either
which is great and I'm gonna be unbiased
well the best part is and unfortunately
in our sport it's one of those things
where you happen to
look at something and then you just [ __ ]
on it
because you're looking at their
weaknesses yeah and I think you don't
sell the sport without yeah you're going
to talk about the weaknesses but you're
going to highlight their strengths
because at the end of the day this is
what these guys train for it's the
person who has the most strength and the
least amount of weaknesses wins I have a
question for you Phil and this may be
the week the the entire audience can
kind of get some perspective here
everyone out there gets judged on their
performance their work performance how
they're looking you know you show up to
the office oh you're rough night
it's constantly you're on social media
people are hating people are commenting
whatever you are putting yourself out
there for the world to see literally
every inch of your body minus right 100.
my question is regarding self-confidence
and Body Image do you ever like get on
stage and be like I don't know I don't
feel so good today or the Judgment the
cause of Judgment at like every like
Instagram models are you know they they
clean up every little image every little
curve are you thinking about it are you
coming thinking that you know before I
get on there I gotta understand the
mentality of it all at the end of the
day break that down you know what to get
him for his birthday already 100 one of
those absolutely I got them yeah okay I
got you bro okay the beginning what
color yeah I'm cheetah no I'm thinking
magenta okay I could do it I can pull
that off would you take that picture and
post it on Instagram
how much money
but but at the end of the day yes
bodybuilders have yes definitely I mean
I'm raising my hand right now the
insecurity absolutely the anxiety that
these guys and these girls are going
through this week they've trained an
entire year
to get ready to go up on stage and be
adjudicated by judges who may or may not
like their physique and then they're
going to be adjudicated by millions of
people on social media to reduce the
noise is what is key for each male and
female that is competing this week
reducing the noise staying within
yourself because there's this thing that
my trainer and I call the F up fairy and
the F up fairy is going to creep into
your mind it's kind of like What
fighters go through
you know they kind of go dark they get
weird and sometimes that's how they get
knocked the hell out in the first round
because they really get in their head
about what's going on it's important
that each and these each of these people
know who the hell they are and realize
that it's you versus you
you cannot control it's not like boxing
where you can go knock the person out
you can't play offense defense you have
to make sure that you Peak the best way
you can and that's it and you just have
to let it let the chips fall but the
insecurity absolutely the anxiety
absolutely I mean I've had it it'll keep
you up at night it'll piss you off I
mean you'll go through various emotions
but that's why the most emotionally
intelligent know how to run this race
and you've won this seven times in a row
Let It Go I think there's certain things
in life you shouldn't aspire to do Mr
obviously let me live my life I say you
skip it let me live a laugh I say you
skip go be go be the wide receiver for
like a local senior uh you know senior
NFL team whatever and you know do that
why exactly we will come root for you I
dare I'll be your biggest fan so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]